Kejayaan algoritma VQE kita bergantung banyak
pada keadaan dan circuit
yang kita pilih dari awal.
Saya Victoria Lipinska dan dalam video ini
kita akan terokai pilihan-pilihan
yang ada dalam merekabentuknya.
Jom tengok lebih dekat
semua elemen
yang ada dalam setiap larian bahagian
kuantum VQE.
Kita mulakan dengan keadaan rujukan,
kadang-kadang dipanggil keadaan awal.
Kita jalankan keadaan rujukan
melalui circuit berparameter yang dipanggil
bentuk variasi
dengan pilihan parameter awal,
dan kita ukur keadaan
dalam asas Hamiltonian
selepas menjalankannya melalui circuit
untuk dapatkan nilai jangkaan. Sekarang
kita akan telusuri setiap elemen ini,
bermula dengan keadaan rujukan.
Pilihan biasa untuk keadaan rujukan
ialah keadaan sifar.
Iaitu keadaan di mana komputer kuantum
sudah pun dimulakan.
Untuk masalah kimia kuantum,
seseorang boleh guna juga
apa yang dipanggil Keadaan Hartree-Fock,
yang merupakan hasil daripada
kaedah Hartree-Fock.
Ringkasnya, teori Hartree-Fock
memberi cara mudah untuk bina
keadaan rujukan dengan menganggar
keadaan asas sistem kuantum.
Ia mencari putaran
dalam ruang keadaan
yang meminimumkan tenaga keadaan asas.
Akhirnya, keadaan rujukan
juga boleh sangat spesifik kepada masalah,
dan kau mungkin nak pilih
keadaan yang ditentukhas.
Dalam kes bila kau tahu sifat-sifat
sistem kau, contohnya, simetri
atau bilangan elektron tertentu
dalam keadaan, kau boleh guna itu
untuk dapatkan penumpuan yang lebih baik
dalam algoritma VQE.
Memilih keadaan rujukan yang bagus
penting untuk penumpuan
keadaan rujukan yang hampir dengan
keadaan asas
boleh buat masalah menumpu
lebih mudah dan cepat.
Sama penting juga
ialah pilihan nilai parameter awal
yang kita masukkan ke dalam bentuk variasi.
Oleh itu, bergantung pada keadaan rujukan
dan parameter awal,
kita mungkin menumpu dengan cepat, perlahan
atau langsung tak menumpu.
Jom tengok plot ini
dan untuk tujuan visualisasi,
bayangkan ruang parameter kita
hanya ada satu parameter.
Keadaan rujukan yang sangat bagus
boleh biarkan kau mula sangat dekat
dengan keadaan asas akhir
dan penumpuan akan jadi cepat.
Sebaliknya, kalau kau mulakan sangat jauh
dari keadaan asas di sini,
keadaan rujukan
a, kau perlu merentasi halangan tenaga yang tinggi
yang membawa kepada penumpuan sangat perlahan
atau langsung tak menumpu.
Kita akan bincangkan ini dengan lebih mendalam
dalam modul pengoptimuman klasik
dalam kursus ini.
Jom tengok sekarang circuit berparameter
yang bertindak pada keadaan rujukan, a.k.a.
bentuk variasi.
Bila circuit ini, yang dikenali,
U daripada theta bertindak pada rujukan
keadaan,
ia menghasilkan apa yang kita panggil keadaan percubaan
psi daripada theta atau kadang-kadang ansatz.
Keadaan ansatz inilah yang kemudiannya
diukur dalam asas yang sesuai
untuk dapatkan nilai jangkaan
untuk tenaga.
Bentuk-bentuk variasi
yang kita bincangkan di sini
dimotivasikan oleh kimia.
Tapi, ingat
bahawa ada juga yang diilhamkan
oleh pembelajaran mesin kuantum
dan algoritma jangka dekat lain
seperti algoritma
pengoptimuman anggaran kuantum.
Jom bincangkan
beberapa pilihan biasa untuk ansatz kimia.
Unitary coupled cluster atau UCC
ialah kaedah yang pada asalnya dicadangkan
dalam penerbitan VQE pertama,
dan ia biasa digunakan dalam
masalah kimia kuantum.
Biasanya,
bila kita berparameterkan keadaan kuantum,
kita bekerja dengan
parameter yang jumlahnya eksponen.
Tapi, untuk buat circuit penyediaan
yang cekap,
kita perlukan bilangan operasi polinomial
dan oleh itu bilangan parameter
yang polinomial juga.
UCC ialah contoh cara menyediakan
keadaan percubaan dengan circuit sedemikian
dan ia diambil daripada kaedah
coupled cluster,
yang merupakan piawaian emas dalam
kimia kuantum.
Pilihan paling biasa ialah unitary
coupled cluster
tunggal dan berganda
ansatz atau UCCSD secara ringkas.
Sebab UCCSD dimotivasikan oleh konfigurasi
elektronik tertentu sesebuah masalah,
kita perlu pastikan kita ada keadaan rujukan
yang mencerminkan sistem dengan betul.
Ini adalah keadaan Hartree-Fock.
Ansatz UCCSD biasanya memberi
anggaran yang baik untuk keadaan asas
sebab ia menangkap keterujaan elektron
tunggal dan berganda dalam molekul tertentu.
Bilangan parameter dalam UCCSD berskala
secara kuadratik dengan bilangan
orbital spin.
UCCSD boleh disesuaikan dengan sangat baik
untuk sesebuah masalah,
tapi malangnya, skala kuadratik
masih menghasilkan circuit yang sangat dalam
yang sukar untuk komputer kuantum
semasa.
Sebab itulah penyelidik IBM mencadangkan
pendekatan yang lebih heuristik,
di mana seseorang boleh sesuaikan bentuk variasi
kepada perkakasan yang mendasari
yang menghasilkan circuit
yang boleh dilaksanakan dengan cekap.
Iaitu, keadaan percubaan diparameterkan
oleh gate kuantum
dan disesuaikan
dengan peranti fizikal yang tersedia.
Ini adalah pendekatan yang sangat heuristik
yang mesra perkakasan.
Berdasarkan contoh-contoh ini, jom tengok
spektrum kemungkinan
yang kita ada untuk nyatakan
bentuk variasi kita.
Banyak dari ini
sudah pun dilaksanakan dalam Qiskit
jadi saya menggalakkan kau cuba sendiri
mana yang paling sesuai
untuk masalah yang cuba kau selesaikan.
Kalau kita tengok graf, di satu pihak
kita ada bentuk variasi
yang sangat heuristik.
Bila spesifisiti masalah rendah, tapi
ia direka untuk dilaksanakan
pada perkakasan sebenar.
Ia juga sangat ekspresif,
dalam erti kata
seseorang boleh nyatakan
banyak keadaan kuantum dengannya.
Tapi,
masalah yang mungkin timbul pada peringkat
pengoptimuman klasik kemudian
ialah menghadapi
apa yang dipanggil barren plateau,
yang akan kita bincangkan dalam modul seterusnya.
Sebaliknya,
kita ada unitary coupled cluster yang sangat spesifik kepada masalah
yang berfungsi dengan baik dalam kimia klasik tapi
sukar dilaksanakan pada perkakasan kuantum
kerana kedalaman circuit yang besar.
Secara umumnya, pengiraan
boleh lebih berjaya kalau kau boleh,
pertama sekali pilih keadaan rujukan
dan set parameter awal
yang mencipta keadaan ansatz
yang dekat dengan keadaan asas.
Dan kedua, elakkan parameter yang tak perlu.
Ini sama ada memperkenalkan
kedalaman circuit yang lebih besar tanpa faedah
atau mencipta ruang parameter yang lebih besar
untuk dicari yang membawa kepada plato
dalam pengoptimuman klasik.
Parameter mana yang perlu ialah satu soalan
spesifik kepada masalah
yang memerlukan pemikiran yang teliti.
Jom bincangkan di mana tetamu kehormat kita,
Hamiltonian, bersembunyi dalam semua ini.
Seperti yang kita belajar dalam bahagian sebelum ini,
Hamiltonian selepas pemetaan qubit
diwakili sebagai jumlah
rentetan operator Pauli yang berwajaran.
Walau bagaimanapun, pada akhirnya,
kita nak nilai nilai jangkaan
Hamiltonian kita pada keadaan ansatz
yang dihasilkan oleh bentuk variasi.
Nasib baik, mekanik
kuantum itu bagus dan linear
dan inilah yang kita guna
untuk dapatkan nilai jangkaan.
Begini cara ia berfungsi.
Kita tahu Hamiltonian ialah jumlah
berwajaran Pauli
kerana kelinearan
nilai jangkaan jumlah
sama dengan jumlah nilai jangkaan
setiap rentetan Pauli.
Nah, ini bagus sebab macam yang kau dah tahu,
ukur dalam asas Pauli
semudah putaran
asas pengukuran piawai.
Daripada ukur nilai jangkaan
pada Hamiltonian besar yang diwakili
sebagai jumlah, kita mula-mula nilai nilai jangkaan
sebutan individu
dan jumlahkan pada akhir
dengan berat yang sepadan.
Inilah sebabnya dalam banyak sumber
kau akan nampak hanya putaran qubit tunggal
selepas ansatz.
Inilah yang melaksanakan Hamiltonian
dalam setiap perlaksanaan circuit.
Dalam video seterusnya,
kita akan terokai apa yang berlaku
semasa langkah pengoptimuman klasik.
Jumpa kau di sana.